oh man um this is wonderful so I have
been asked a hundred times today if I'm
nervous and honestly I haven't been
nervous until now I've been nervous for
three months but today I've just been
excited and I can't tell you how much of
an honor it is to even be here to even
when i made the semi-finalists i like
was just like are you serious that's not
true you're lied to me but to even be
one of the top three is just I can't I
can't even explain it it's something
that I've never dreamed of in my entire
life it's nothing that I've ever thought
would ever even come close to me I
thought I was going to be an electrician
in a town of 800 people and that's not
to say that that's not a good thing to
do but I never thought that I would be
able to talk in front of all of you and
be recognized by something that the
entire world knows there are so many
people in my life that have believed in
me and never given up on me and have led
to this moment right now people that I
love dearly people that I will always
hold really close to my heart I guess I
should probably name them
first and foremost I want to thank the
academy yeah I gotta say it sweet
they've been wonderful they put us up in
a sweet a dope hotel and they fed us so
much food they got us drunk they like it
was awesome good job guys like well done
all of the people that like we've worked
with closely and I like honestly I don't
have any paper I'm just totally winging
it right now so I'm going to try to say
your names but you know who you are the
people that have been closest to us from
the Academy this week I love you dearly
and you'll always be people that I
really admire and I love I want to thank
I want to thank my school depaul
university first-timer yeah um yes first
time T'Pol has ever been recognized for
the student academy awards and it feels
incredible the amount of things that
they've said about me in the amount of
gratitude and the things they've said it
it is such a huge honor I can't tell you
enough I want to think I want to thank
my family all of them in general they
shares we've been my biggest support in
my entire life but I want to be specific
I want to thank the two people that I
lived with for the past two years who
have not only been some of the biggest
influences in my life but they kept me
alive while I made that I'm not even
kidding you they kept me and my dog
alive because i worked for 40 hours
straight and then i slept two hours and
then I worked for 40 hours straight and
I slept for two hours and they were the
ones that made sure that I was eating
and that i was sleeping and then i still
had a pulse at the end of the day Mike
and Heather voice they're wonderful I
can't tell you enough how much I love
you guys I want to thank my other
brother and sister law Luke and Carrie
boys
they can't be here right now because
they're bringing my first me so I'm
gonna be an uncle for the first time in
like a month and they're bringing that
into the world that's the thing people
bring other human beings into this world
is that crazy or what um and Luke has
been my biggest fan film mentor in my
life the dude is dudes a little bit
weird how much he loves felon let's be
real like did he but he's amazing and
he's I can't tell you enough how much
he's influenced me I want to also thank
my grandma who is here tonight Bev Bauer
she has been such an inspiration her and
her her and her late husband Sam Bauer
have woken up every morning for the past
28 years and prayed for me every morning
their entire life every single morning
in their support has always gone
appreciated um I want to thank my mom
who is here tonight who has been my
biggest support she has paid for so much
stuff guys you don't understand like I'm
in debt I'm in debt to you know the the
nation because of my you know my student
loans but they don't have [ __ ] on her
seriously she is wonderful she has she
never complains she you know she goes
Carter well we'll talk about it you know
but she is wonderful she is the best
support I've ever had in my entire life
and a last but certainly not least this
Ward is actually for my father who died
10 years ago in influence this film this
film is about breaking down your world
breaking down around you in finding
something new out of it
and my father died 10 years ago and he
was my best friend and he was everything
to me and this I want to thank him for
the artistic ability that he gave me in
the vision that he gave me without that
without him I would have nothing this is
for him and I love you dad
so with that said thank you all for
being here I hope you have a wonderful
night and congratulations to all the
other winners